[Musica]
quanti di voi si svegliano la mattina
convinti di fare la differenza questa è
la domanda che ha fatto una nostra
studentessa di 16 anni katherine ai suoi
compagni di classe e nessuno ha alzato
la mano
e questa una domanda che mi faccio
anch'io da diverso tempo da sempre in
particolare sono appassionata di temi
ambientali ricorda piccola suv primo
national geographic vedevo le foto
dell'amazzonia che bruciava e poi
crescendo mi sono accorta che i problemi
ambientali non erano solo dall'altra
parte del mondo ma erano anche intorno a
noi erano dei problemi globali ma anche
locali pensa ai problemi della
cementificazione che riguardavano
proprio il paesaggio che vivevo tutti i
giorni i problemi quindi della perdita
diciamo di identità del nostro paesaggio
e anche di noi stessi e poi pensa ai
problemi del cambiamento climatico che
sono a livello globale e che hanno reso
una singola specie la specie umana in
grado di modificare irrimediabilmente il
clima dando vita a quella che è l'epoca
dell'antropocene tutte queste
problematiche mi hanno sempre spinto a
cercare di fare qualcosa e ho provato a
cercare la mia strada quindi mi sono
laureato all'università ho fatto vari
tipi di esperienze dopodiché sono
approdata in un centro di ricerche che
si occupava proprio di questi temi del
paesaggio del consumo di suolo della
valutazione di piani programmi era
quello per cui avevo studiato però
sentivo quando tornavo a casa la sera
non mi sentivo veramente soddisfatta
sentivo che mancava effettivamente
qualcosa non riuscivo a capire bene che
cosa e poi cosa è successo
penserete ho lasciato mollato tutto ha
cambiato completamente vita
no in realtà ero attaccata a quel tipo
di lavoro che avevo perché comunque
c'erano i miei compagni con cui avevo
frequentato l'università il lavoro era
gradevole ero diciamo nella mia confort
l'on
quindi non avevo il coraggio di cambiare
poi è successo un elemento esterno un
elemento che ha portato alla
diciamo chiusura del mio contratto
perché erano finiti i fondi per quella
ricerca e questa cosa mi ha messo molto
in crisi
non sapevo effettivamente che cosa che
cosa fare avevo due strade aperte
davanti a me che vedevo in quel momento
o cercare diciamo di arrivare in una
impresa tradizionale quindi utilizzare
la mia laurea quello che avevo studiato
o provare partire da me ed alle mie
passioni e provare a mettermi in gioco e
ho scelto questa seconda strada e quindi
ho fondato un'associazione che si
occupava proprio dei temi del paesaggio
dell'ambiente e cercava di coinvolgere i
comuni le istituzioni
man mano che portava avanti questi
progetti la cosa di cui mi sono accorta
è che stavo attingendo dei talenti che
non avevo mai considerato in particolare
va considerato carriere come
completamente separate le mie passioni
per l'arte e la mia passione per
l'ambiente e tramite quella esperienza
io stavo unendo tante cose che mi
piacevano tanti interessi e ho scoperto
anche dei talenti che non pensavo di
avere rispetto proprio alla capacità di
connettere le persone di gestire
progetti di utilizzare l'arte holt e
l'altro come uno strumento di
comunicazione di progetti ambientali e
quindi tante cose che non sapevo di
avere sono emerse e tutto questo
percorso mi ha portato alla
consapevolezza di cercare di condividere
quello che avevo appreso di me poi che
poi era riuscita a fare concretamente
con i giovani quelle nuove generazioni e
in particolare a lavorare su di loro per
dare degli strumenti di cambiamento
delle loro vite e poi del mondo del loro
territorio del loro contesto
è nata così l'azienda che ho creato che
si occupa proprio di questo è che dal
2014 ha coinvolto più di 8000 ragazzi in
tutta italia su progetti per fare la
differenza e questo per me era
inimmaginabile e quando pensava questa
possibile strada era completamente
inimmaginabile e mi ricordo nel
corridoio un collega proprio quando
stavo chiudendo la mia esperienza di
lavoro precedente che mi aveva chiesto
ma cosa farai dopo gli ho detto io so
che cosa voglio fare sa che voglio
occuparmi di giovani ambiente
in qualche modo lo farò e ho scoperto
una sicurezza anche qui che non pensavo
mi appartenesse e offrire agli
striscioni degli strumenti di
cambiamento è stata un'esperienza che ha
permesso in qualche modo di cambiare le
cose partendo più in primis dal talento
la cosa infatti su cui vogliamo
ragionare vogliamo portare nelle classi
è proprio far pensare ai giovani quali
sono farli riflettere su quali sono i
loro talenti quali sono le loro capacità
le loro attitudini e sembra una cosa
scontata ma spesso a scuola non si
ragiona su quali sono effettivamente le
proprie capacità quindi una domanda che
facciamo è in particolare chiedere loro
chiedere ai ragazzi che cosa sei brava a
fare che cosa ti piace fare e anche che
cosa gli altri le persone che ti
vogliono bene ti riconoscono come
qualcosa in cui sei bravo effettivamente
e quando i ragazzi sono obbligati a
riflettere su questo vediamo che le cose
cambiano
a volte qualcuno dice no io non so fare
assolutamente niente
poi prova a riflettere effettivamente
trova un talento trova qualcosa e in
particolare la una delle storie che
volevo portare oggi quindi come i
talenti e ricercare i propri talenti
possa effettivamente farci attingere
delle energie che non pensavamo di avere
mi raccontava appunto la storia di uno
dei nostri studenti
la storia di uno studente che ha passato
cinque ore chiuso in un armadio
adesso vi spiegherò perché per me magari
anche per voi un pastello è
semplicemente un pastello per questo
ragazzo un pastello era uno strumento
per educare le giovani generazioni per
poter insegnare ai bambini a disegnare
disegnare la natura e poter insegnare
loro che non si butta via niente e che
quando si pianta quello che rimane del
pastello che è in quel caso il passo
alla cava invitato octavia era un
pastello con un seme quando si pianta
quello che rimane del pastello si può
generare una pianta che dà origine a un
frutto un fiore che è dello stesso
colore del paese
bello ottavia nel nostro studente ha
creato questo progetto una start up che
realizza questi pastelli integrati con
il seme proprio per i bambini e era un
ragazzo che veniva considerato da lui
stesso si considerava una persona in
qualche modo uno studente in qualche
modo mediocre non non aveva del
commitment come definiva lui stesso e in
questo progetto si è appassionato
talmente tanto e ha scoperto che quello
che faceva nel proprio tempo libero
quindi quello che faceva al di fuori
della scuola a dedicarsi ai video
dedicarsi alla comunicazione poteva
effettivamente essere qualcosa su cui
lavorare sia messo allora in gioco
all'interno di questo progetto e ha
passato cinque ore chiusa in un armadio
per cercare di registrare il video della
sua start up che fosse il più perfetto
possibile perché i vestiti all'interno
dell'armadio assorbivano il suono e
questa esperienza gli ha permesso in
qualche modo di cambiare la sua vita
perchè ha scoperto di avere questo
talento nella comunicazione è riuscito a
entrare in università importante che si
occupa di comunicazione ha vinto delle
borse di studio e qui da una riflessione
sui propri talenti è riuscito in qualche
modo a trovare quella che è la sua
strada
questa è un esempio appunto di come
attingendo alle proprie risorse si possa
fare la differenza in primis in se
stessi
la seconda cosa che volevo portare era
proprio l'importanza di mettere a
contatto gli studenti i giovani con
qualcosa che non conoscono qualcosa che
li può effettivamente ispirare quello
che abbiamo notato è che portarli a
contatto con realtà che sono realtà
innovative ma anche con luoghi che sono
diversi dal solito può effettivamente
fare la differenza nei ragazzi e questo
che trovate sulla slider è appunto un
biglietto che ci ha lasciato un nostro
studente uno studente di una scuola che
era in un contesto abbastanza difficile
uno studente che i propri professori
definivano uno studente che era
abbastanza difficile e attraverso
un'esperienza in montagna
giorni con un focus sui temi ambientali
effettivamente questo ragazzo ha
comunicato in maniera completamente
diverse alla fine se n'è andato
lasciandoci questo biglietto si è
sentito libero si è riscoperto e ha
riscoperto anche un modo differente di
comunicare se stesso agli altri
l'ultima cosa di cui volevo parlare
quindi sicuramente un percorso per fare
la differenza riguarda la scoperta dei
propri talenti
il venire a contatto con qualcosa che è
fuori dal nostro quotidiano
quindi uscire da quelli che sono i
nostri confini soliti diciamo e venire a
contatto con realtà che magari pensiamo
a priori non ci possono interessare la
terza cosa che però vogliamo portare nei
giovani e nelle scuole cercare di
aiutarli a fare la differenza anche in
un contesto legato al loro territorio e
quindi quello che facciamo è proprio
cercare di aiutarli a ragionare rispetto
alla collettività all'inizio vi parlavo
di catherine i suoi compagni di classe
non hanno alzato la mano rispetto alla
domanda che le aveva fatto come si fa
avere un impatto
però poi tutti insieme ai katherine ei
suoi compagni si sono messi e sono
riusciti a per realizzare un progetto
che effettivamente trasformato la città
la città in cui risiedeva la loro
squadra città di como si sono messi
insieme e hanno progettato un idea
semplice un applicativo che incentivava
le persone ad andare a piedi e quindi
faceva in modo di cercare di risolvere
quello che era un problema della città
di como in qualche modo l'inquinamento
ambientale l'inquinamento dell'aria e il
fatto che il centro storico stessa in
qualche modo perdendo il suo centro di
interesse e quindi questi ragazzi hanno
realizzato questo applicativo hanno
creato una rete di commercianti che
davano degli sconti alle persone che
andavano a piedi hanno mobilitato i
cittadini e hanno sensibilizzato
centinaia di persone su queste tematiche
organizzando delle camminate delle
camminate intorno alla città con
famiglie bambini più piccoli i genitori
e così via ed è stato bello perché tutti
insieme hanno capito che potevano
cercare di approfondire
proprio talento ma potevano anche
metterlo in connessione con altri e
potevano cercare di realizzare progetti
che portavano un valore alla propria
città
quindi questo è il messaggio che vi
voglio lasciare tutti noi come cittadini
studenti genitori formatori quali
comunque sia il nostro ruolo
possiamo cercare di ascoltare i nostri
talenti di metterli in gioco e di
lavorare tutti per la costruzione di un
mondo migliore
grazie
[Applauso]